my next speaker from Virginia is James
laferty who is fighting the
fight of he's the chairman of vast the
Virginia anti Sharia task
force good to see
you we held the best story for last and
I'm about to make big
news before I left Virginia today I was
called to the White
House there in the conference room sat
Imam
rou and now don't all applaud Barack
Hussein
Obama I said Mr President why am I here
why do you want me here he said it's not
my
meeting all of a sudden the door came
open and the first thing I noticed was
was his hair it was Donald
Trump he came in and he said Imam rou
you've insulted a great
people you have walked on the graves of
Brave
Americans and let's all say it together
Imam rou you're
[Applause]
fired and then there was a pause and he
got up and he turned around and he
said Obama I'll see you in November
2012 I promised you the last time that I
was here that if you needed people from
Virginia call me we'll line up the
pickup trucks and we'll come up
95 before I left that day I got calls
from Tennessee Texas and Mississippi
they're coming too
America loves New York but it
particularly loves New York today you
can feel its arm around you on this
special day on this important day we're
here we want to be here with you just as
we couldn't be that day but we're going
to be here from now on we're going to
stop these people they have picked the
wrong
fight God bless you